welcome back to CBS morning's a man
freed after more than three decades
Behind Bars May soon learn if he can
stay free Crossley Green's conviction
for murder was overturned back in 2018
by a federal court and for the last two
years he has been a free man but another
Court reinstated his conviction and now
he's asking the Supreme Court for help
if the justices aside not to hear this
case we may learn their decision
tomorrow he'll likely go back to prison
Aaron Murray Aaron Moriarty is her name
she's not changed it she's been
following green story for many years now
Erin good morning to you this is a
stunning turn of events for Mr Green
well it is good morning Gail the odds
are stacked against Crosley green the
Supreme Court accepts very few cases for
review in the last term out of almost 5
000 petitions filed only 70 cases were
argued and it's not the facts of Green's
case that justices will be looking at
it's whether the case presents a
substantial Federal legal issue that
needs resolving by the highest court in
the country so here's how green got to
this point
since Crosley green came home
unconditional release in April 2021 the
65 year old has saved her Joys that most
people take for granted strawberry ice
cream a full-time job and time with
family you're good come on green spent
32 years in prison 19 of them on death
row for the murder of a young Florida
man Charles chip Flynn Flynn's former
girlfriend Kim halik told police a black
man robbed them and then shot 22 year
old Flint halek pick Green a local
small-time drug dealer out of this photo
lineup although the Citrus Grove where
the shooting occurred was Pitch Black
I really didn't need a real good look at
him I was really scared there was no
physical evidence tying green to the
crime no fingerprints no weapon no blood
but green was convicted by an all-white
jury in 1990. I didn't kill that young
man Crosley green always insisted he had
nothing to do with the murder I
kidnapped no one I killed no one I did
none of those things
and there was evidence to support his
claim when Brevard County deputy sheriff
Mark rixey and Sergeant Diane Clark
arrived at the scene Flynn was still
alive first words out of his mouth were
get me out of here how long ago did he
mention anything about an assailant nope
no I'm thinking what the hell is going
on here rixie and Clark even told the
trial prosecutor of their concerns back
then and he took notes Mark and Diane
suspect the girl did it
she changed her story a couple of times
but the prosecutor who believed talek
was innocent of the crime never turned
over those notes to Green's defense team
this is the evidence of Innocence that
was hidden by the prosecutor Keith
Harrison is one of Crosley Green's
attorneys in 2018 a federal judge ruled
that the notes should have been
disclosed and overturned Green's
conviction but the State of Florida
appealed that decision and three and a
half years later a court of appeals
sided with the state this court decided
that the withheld notes would not have
changed the verdict to trial and ruled
that green shouldn't even be in federal
court because he failed to exhaust all
his claims in State Court first but
Crosley green ever The Optimist had this
to say it may take more time for you
sister to get right but it's going to
get right eventually
you know and you still have faith that
the system is going to get it right
eventually of course I'm not going to
give up my faith you know what I'm
saying I came too far
to give up my faith look what my faith
got me here again with you
with my family
you know with friends all I do I get up
I pray
for another day
yeah he's 65 years of age he's not the
only one who is hoping the Supreme Court
takes this case um there have been a
number of prosecutors State Court judges
um who are and professors who are asking
the Supreme Court to review the case
with these Friends of the Court briefs
and here's the big issue here
um there's a concern that if in case
this case stands it Waters down one of
the most important protections for
criminal defendants and that's a
requirement for the prosecutor to hand
over yes uh that that material
exculpatory evidence and in this case
remember this was 1990 back in Florida
and crosley's trial attorney wanted to
say I think the girl did it but he
didn't want to offend the jury imagine
if he had those notes and he could have
put on these two white First Responders
who would have been saying it so so it's
almost like the evidence in support of
Crosley green doesn't matter at this
point it makes you think that you hope
the Supreme Court has the evidence that
you just showed us here to show the
discrepancies but they won't be looking
at that they're going to be looking at
frustrating I know but they're looking
at the important legal issue of weather
then does this water down because it was
a Supreme Court case that gave us this
protection yeah um it was the 1963 Brady
versus Maryland so whether the Supreme
Court thinks that this Waters it down
too much there's a number of different
legal issues that the Supreme talking
about the system where what everyone
really cares about is did he do it or
not or not yes I have been here so many
times talking about that when you get to
the Appellate Court really innocence
isn't the big issue it's deeper than
that it's the legal issue and Aaron
you're saying the Supreme Court rarely
takes cases I know we'll know Monday
actually I I misspoke it's next Monday
they will issue which cases they take
and which ones they don't the fact that
he still has faith in the system says a
lot about the hope that he clings to I
know for sure a lot about him a lot
about him yeah